you're the first interview that we've
given since all of this we've placed no
parameters on this interview uh the
evidence has been turned over to us
um and it was heartbreaking and if i say
something
you mark it in your book cause it'll be
the truth
so i welcome that lawsuit
well todd julie it's so nice to chat
with y'all today and sit down with you
here in nashville
thank you for having us i can't believe
it's been nine seasons i'm sure for you
you're like what
did you think that the show would be
running this long you know i don't think
that any of us
you know the network you know which is
you know usa has been a wonderful
partner for us
i don't think any of us thought that we
would be doing this for nine seasons
you know i think in the very beginning
when we started season one we felt like
wow you know if we can just make it two
seasons
then you know we won't be a failure yeah
and you know here we are
wrapping up the season nine and having a
spin-off as well
and a spin-off with growing up chrisley
which is in its season three getting
ready to go into season four
and you know we've been very blessed i
mean we've been very blessed but i think
that that's because god has aligned us
with wonderful partners yeah awesome oh
my god
great you ready to get your permit
where the hell are we a place that i
shouldn't even be in
what are y'all doing none of your
business
now tell me this how much of the show
was scripted
well you know i'd like to say that it's
all scripted
especially after the fact i would love
to say it's all scripted
but you can't script the dysfunction
that goes on in our lives
and i remember the very first first day
we ever filmed chrisley knows best it
was day one
season one it was savannah's 16th
birthday
august the 11th and i remember us having
this scene
in a hotel down in buckhead and
we didn't know what we were doing but i
remember getting in the car
and i looked at todd and i said that
really just happened you know i've
watched
all these shows for years and i've
thought you know
that stuff is scripted there's no way
that happened and
after that day one i'm like that really
just happened
and there was like no script it just
happened
so where do you see yourselves
progressing to after
reality tv what does that life look like
um i think that i will
probably move into some form of politics
really um i think that i will go back to
my home state
of south carolina and
i want to be a grandfather i want to i
want to help raise my grandchildren
while also trying to help make this
country that i love dearly
a better place for everyone now what do
you think of that julie especially the
politics aspect
because you already got yourself into
reality tv you are right now you're
about to die well it cannot get any
worse
there's nothing else for you to know
about us it's all out there so there's
no bombshells
let me just say this we've been together
a long time and
i'm not bailing now so politics or no
politics
i'm going to stick in there we're going
to do what we've always done which is
come together as a team and see what
happens
fair enough all right but how has
reality television
tested or taken a toll on your marriage
you know i
people ask me all the time what's the
best and worst part about
having the show and tv and all this and
i said well
you know imagine every day of your life
going to work with your spouse with your
adult children
with your minor children and with your
mother-in-law oh my god
just imagine every day that being that
being what you're working with
that's a lot right and then living with
them in real life exactly
and that it's a lot um but i do think
we've always
we sat the kids down before the show we
ever started filming the show
and we said to them this is a job
yes they are going to be in our home in
our life
filming who we are but at the end of the
day
this is a job for them and it is our job
to make sure that our family is intact
when
all this is over it's admirable and it's
great that you set the children down but
they're
in that you guys have been able to be
for the most part this strong
family unit and army amongst yourselves
but of course
you get the trolls on the internet or
you get the headlines
um and there have been a tremendous
amount of headlines about the two of you
your children um
what headline in particular maybe has
been one that has been most hurtful to
your family
we've told our children that for us to
allow someone that we've never met
or their opinion to matter to us is
giving power to something that
we shouldn't even care about and so we
choose not to give free rent in our in
our minds
to people that just don't matter to us
you know regarding headlines you know
there's never really been any headlines
about our marriage that have bothered us
because we know who we are
i guess the the thing that probably hurt
the most
was um the extortion thing
with my oldest daughter lindsay okay so
let's let's go
there so lindsay accused you and chase
of extorting her which you vehemently
denied that's correct so where does that
stand how did that start
um you know listen without going into
too much detail because
she is my daughter and i love her um
lindsay there was just some kind of
emotional
battle that lindsay has had within
herself and you know
jealousy with amongst her siblings and
you know it started out with you know
savannah having way more social media
followers and then it started out that
lindsay wasn't getting enough time on
the show
and and then you know it was
you know that lindsay was in atlanta and
we were all here and you know we wanted
the show to be authentic
and you know why are you here in these
episodes if your life is in atlanta
and you know lindsay wasn't at that time
willing to allow the cameras into her
personal life she wouldn't tell
the world anything and so you know and
then we find out that there never really
was a sex tape
okay so you're speaking on two fronts
first the extortion of the sex state
but secondly was the fact that allegedly
two of your children went to authorities
they went to the georgia department of
revenue
uh the evidence has been turned over to
us um
and it was heartbreaking as a parent
where do you go from there
how do you get through that you know i
don't know i don't know i you know i
pray to god
every day you ask the question what has
been the hardest thing
it has been the hardest thing because i
don't know where you go from that
when you have a child that you have
loved the way that lindsay has been
loved
and and this happens so they went to
authorities but was there any
truth with what they presented to the
authorities
because you guys have been accused and
and you're facing charges from state
uh evasion charges
that's the state charges have been
dismissed but where do you now stand
with the federal charges um
we're still working through that process
i think there was a lot of stuff that
came out
um about four weeks ago that
the that was not known to the government
there's one other case a defamation
case yeah things stand on that thing oh
i love that case
i have never been more excited in my
life for something
because here's the here's the thing
about defamation your defense
against slander is the truth and if i
say something
you mark it in your book because it'll
be the truth
so i welcome that lawsuit now what she's
not aware of is what we're sitting on
well todd chrisley has spoken yes
he has indeed yes we haven't sat down
with anyone
you're the first interview that we've
given since all of this we placed no
parameters on this interview we said ask
us whatever you want to ask us
and you know you ask the question what's
been the most difficult
that has been the most difficult and
kyle has come to us and he has asked for
forgiveness and
you know he has struggled with drugs and
he's clean and he's doing
doing the best that he's done and i
can't tell you how long
lindsay has not solved that remorse i
want to know more about
lindsay she recently announced that she
is getting a divorce have you
heard from lindsay since she announced
that news of her divorce
um i receive i have not heard from
lindsay have you reached out to her
i have not um i
received a text message from lindsay
about two weeks ago
and i turned that over to our attorneys
why um
because we don't feel that it's safe to
communicate
um even to say i hope you're doing well
no
because every time that i've done that
it's been twisted and turned
and so we can't in the position that
we're in we can't run that risk
so we turned it over to our attorney and
we let them handle it
i'm sad that my daughter chose to make
decisions that she's made in her life
um but you know when you get married
marriage is supposed to be forever
and anytime a third party gets involved
it's not a good thing
so a third party got involved in her
husband there was a third party involved
the first go-round and i think they
tried to work through that
and i don't know what happened this
second time how does it make you feel
julie because you welcomed these
children in
from todd's first marriage you adopted
lindsay
lindsay came to me after she turned 18
and
said this is what i've done i've already
contacted
an attorney i've already had the papers
drawn up
would you be willing to adopt me
and i was floored i have loved these
children since they were
five and six years old and i said
a piece of paper does not dictate my
love for you
but if you feel that you need that and
that will help you
then absolutely you know julie said
something the other day that i thought
was so profound and i was like wow i'm
so glad to be married to this woman
she said the one thing i will never
apologize for is the kind of mother that
i have been
and when you can say that as a parent
you're on solid ground yeah
there was never any extortion that was
all used for headlines
that was used to gain social media
following lindsay went and sat
and in front of the press with an
attorney and dr phil
and dr phil did you back door
secret source the federal government
against your family
no you were not a whistleblower
that turned the federal government onto
your family's wrongdoing
no did you want to bring chrisley knows
best
down in flames no every ounce of it was
a lie and now she has to sit for a
deposition next month
and all of this stuff it's going to be
videoed
so all of this stuff is coming out that
she's done
and that she now knows that we know
she's done right
where do you go from here you're
currently a estranged
but you're not doing anything in regards
to legal matters against your daughter
she's our daughter and i will tell you
that the anger was there for a long time
because the anger
you know the devil works with you with
the anger revenge and anger belongs to
the devil
so i walked with the devil i was dancing
with the devil there for a minute
and god allowed me to get back into my
faith and to walk in faith and forget
about the fear
and i had to remember that i am a father
first
and that you know when you have children
and you discipline your children the
world's not going to see that
but when todd chrisley disciplines his
children it's a headline
julie and i came from very humble
beginnings and it was
our life's goal to make sure that our
children always had more than what we
came from
and i gave them that a million times
more
so if i had my time to go over there
would have been
less cars less vacation homes
i would have made them get jobs and i
didn't do that
because i was feeding that child in me
that
didn't come from it when i thought i was
doing it to benefit my own children
how is kyle doing because you guys
finally reconciled last season on the
show
i want my family back and i'll do
whatever it takes in order to make that
happen
you know that i love you yeah and i
would want nothing
nothing more than that he's faced so
many issues with drugs he's had his own
demons
yes where did the two of you stand today
we're great we're probably in the best
place we've ever been
um i he came to me and asked for
forgiveness and
he told us what his part was and we
confirmed it and
we what do you do yeah you have no
choice but to forgive your child
i've always known that kyle was a good
person that he had a good heart
but they have struggled with abandonment
issues their entire life because their
mother walked away
and so you know that loss for them
i'm sorry far um that was a marriage
that
should have never happened you know my
ex got pregnant
we got married that was the town that we
came from a little small country town
and we got married but there was never
any true love
julius julie is the love of my life
and i'm and i'm grateful to god that i
can say that that belongs to one woman
i have been many but um
i've only been in love with one how long
do you foresee the show running
and when will be the time that you say
okay we got to walk away from reality tv
you know i i think that
the show is going to go on for as long
as people tune in
and they want to know what's going on in
our lives but come on in your mind todd
are you thinking okay we got it in us
for like two more years one more
year five months i really don't no i
really don't i feel like that that's
god's timing and that he'll let us know
when it's time for us to walk away
you know listen i grew up in the south
so did you
um and my grandmother used to always say
that you know
to my aunt you know a lady always knows
when to leave
and so you know we don't want to
overstay our welcome in anyone's lives
and i think that the viewers will tell
us when it's time to walk away